what's going on guys so as promised on
my Facebook and Twitter I'm going to be
doing a series of Mission Impossible
reviews leading up to rogue nation they
may be asking yourself Chris didn't you
do that like four years ago yeah I did
but Paramount's kind of annoyed with the
fact that I used to put trailers in my
reviews and they gave me copyright
notices on all of them so I had to
remove them but you know what that's
kind of a blessing in disguise because I
didn't put as much effort into my
reviews back then and I'd love to cover
those four films in a more in-depth way
so let's get started
with Mission Impossible and as a warning
this review will contain some spoilers
for the film because you know what it
came out almost twenty years ago so if
you haven't seen it yet I would suggest
checking it out it's a lot of fun but
let's get started I've been a fan of
Mission Impossible almost my entire life
and not just because of these films my
dad showed me the original television
show that they're based on when I was a
kid we used to watch it together on
television all the time and when this
movie came out I was super into the
Nintendo 64 game for Mission Impossible
as well even though Tom Cruise didn't
let him use his likeness I thought the
game was actually a lot of fun back in
the day and I love the things that they
say the voices in this game are amazing
like sometimes when you shoot somebody
in the game you get this weird radio
transmission that says way to go go I
used to rent this game from blockbuster
like every couple of weeks to try to get
farther in the game because five days
just weren't enough for me I would I'd
wanted more all the time
the Brian DePalma directed this movie
and it stars Tom Cruise as Ethan Hunt at
the time of this movie's release he was
not known to be an action star a lot of
people weren't sure if he could pull
this off because up until then he was
the risky business guy or the few good
men guy or the firm guy you know he was
a good actor he was incompetent dramas
and comedies but he wasn't really an
action star yet and with this movie he
proved that not only was he very into
the idea of doing stunt work but he
really could sell those stunts and make
them look realistic while also giving a
charismatic performance and it's by far
the most suspenseful entry in the entire
series this movie was much more focused
on building suspense and tension and
that's one of the things that I loved
about the first Mission Impossible movie
now one of the things these movies have
that really benefit it is the fact that
the exposition scenes that are required
to explain to the audience what's going
to happen we all want
that we want to hear the tape we want to
hear them say the famous this tape will
self-destruct in five seconds we want to
hear all those things because there's
staples of Mission Impossible and yet
they're giving us an exposition scene
which a lot of writers and filmmakers
are always trying to figure out how to
make less obvious but with the Mission
Impossible movies similar to the Indiana
Jones movies when they are explaining
their mission and setting it up we want
to hear all these things because they're
fun exciting summer movie things we like
hearing spies get together and talk
about what they're going to do and their
famous gadgets and all that kind of
stuff his direction is actually very
smart here he does a lot of really
subtle things in the timing of the
editing in the way he moves the camera
in the way he frames certain shots and
took it way beyond a summer blockbuster
level of direction you might expect from
a movie called Mission Impossible like
in the opening scene with the team
hearing from Jim Phelps almost always
the team is framed in a wide we don't
get like a really obvious close-up here
telling us who our hero is the focus
here is on the team Ethan Hunt has not
yet proved himself to us as the audience
so he frames the team in a wide to show
us this team as a whole and that these
are the guys were going to be focusing
on also on a side note as a kid I always
wanted the fruit stripe gum because it
reminded me of the iconic gum from this
movie red light green light press them
together hasta lasagna don't get any
Anya Emilio Estevez nice to see you in
this movie buddy and what I was most
satisfied with watching this movie last
night is that even though it's almost 20
years old this movie holds up extremely
well the action is all very well-crafted
it still looks realistic it's very
tightly edited and the pace never wavers
in fact this is one of the movies from
the 90s that I think has actually gotten
better with age Brian DePalma uses a lot
of old-fashioned techniques in this
movie like cross dissolves if you watch
carefully he uses a lot of cross
dissolves in this movie as well as fade
outs and this gives it sort of an
old-fashioned 1960s sense to it another
thing I love about this movie is its
portrayal of Ethan Hunt he's a very
vulnerable hero he's not a super hero in
this movie early on in the movie you can
feel his distress he's constantly
worried after his entire team dies
around him and he meets with Kittredge
in that restaurant and they have that
very off kilter scene in which he starts
to suspect things or go
on and he describes that all the people
in the restaurant are the same people he
saw at the party that's a brilliant
scene but you feel his mind starting to
snap a little bit throughout that moment
and De Palma's use of Dutch angles
really sold that but after that great
scene with a water tank exploding and he
runs back to the safehouse he's still
extremely paranoid he's breaking up
light bulbs all over the floor in case
someone steps on them he's looking
around every corner you can tell this
guy's essentially a fugitive now he's a
man on the run the choice to make our
hero basically a fugitive made for a
much more interesting protagonist it
made his mission seem impossible
it made him seem insignificant and
that's one of the things that I thought
made his character a lot more
interesting and some guy you could
actually root for because he really does
feel like the little guy even though he
has all this knowledge of IMF now one of
my flaws with this movie is its
portrayal of the Internet the movie came
out in 1996 the Internet was very new
and filmmakers at that time we're still
kind of like we can get away with some
stuff because the Internet's like this
this thing this floaty thing out there
that not everyone knows about yet so
we'll just make the internet do all
these things and the portrayal of the
Internet in this movie is a little bit
laughable especially if you watch it now
it's by far the most dated aspect of
this movie also the plot it's very hard
to follow I've seen the film multiple
times now and I still have to pay
attention to every word out of these
characters mouths to make sure I don't
miss anything but it's that really a
negative that you actually have to pay
attention I don't think so
I think films that force you to pay
attention to every line of dialogue
that's great I'm sick and tired of
movies where I can actually just sort of
check out and not miss anything
Mission Impossible is the rare summer
blockbuster that uses your brain that
makes you really have to pay attention
and once we meet Ving Rhames and jean
reno as the support i got to say Ving
Rhames in this movie is perfect casting
I'm telling you there is no other actor
I can envision playing Luther stickell
he is such a great idea in fact if I
were to read this script I would never
picture Ving Rhames as this character
because it's a computer hacker
he loves his technology he's really
great at hacking into government things
if you read that script would you
picture Ving Rhames
I wouldn't I would picture like some
skinny nerdy guy with glasses but Ving
Rhames as luther stickell is one of the
things that made each Mission Impossible
movie as good as it could be I also love
the setup for the CIA scene
the way Tom Cruise explains it and the
way Brian DePalma shows it to us because
it sets it up as a truly impossible task
and you're sitting there and you're
getting really tense thinking about all
these things these characters are going
to have to do that's one of the best
ways to set up a scene that's meant to
build suspense you have to make it seem
insurmountable you have to describe it
in some way that makes us as the
audience understand just how hard and
difficult it's going to be and the
infiltration of the CIA remains one of
the most suspenseful scenes I've ever
seen
I get goosebumps every time the knife
drops the use of minimal music and
almost no sound was not only a ballsy
move for a big summer blockbuster but is
seen that each film thus far has
tributed in one sense or another always
having at least one sequence with Ethan
hanging from a rope and one of the best
scenes in this movie is when Ethan
discovers that Jim is still alive and
then they have this conversation where
Jim tells his version of the story and
Ethan is agreeing with him through his
dialogue he's able to maintain this
facade that he understands him and
agrees with him but we see in his head
that he's actually figuring out the real
details of Jim Phelps's betrayal it's a
fantastic scene that's really clever and
danny elfman added a lot with his
musical choir in the background now I
love the train scene in this movie and
almost every shot and it still holds up
remarkably well almost twenty years
later I loved Danny Elfman's score
throughout the scene and one of my
favorite moments that no one ever talks
about is when Ethan connects the
helicopter to the back of the Train
turns towards Krieger and just screams
Adam there was no dialogue necessary
that screamed to his face just sold
everything you needed to know this scene
also contains one of my favorite movie
explosions of all time with Tom Cruise
literally being blown into frame it's
the kind of explosion that only a 90s
action movie could get away with and I
love Elfman's use of the theme in this
moment it's so adrenaline fueled every
time I see that scene where he leaps on
to the edge of the helicopter takes the
gum and sticks it onto the chopper I
love it it's such a great moment it's
like you see the protagonist he's
proving himself all along the way he's
not just a grunt worker who can
impersonate other people he's proving
himself throughout the entire movie he
steals the NOC list from the CIA and in
this moment he rises above his former
boss who is now his villain and it just
makes for this amazing thing where it's
like Ethan Hunt
you are the ultimate badass good job man
and also this is a really minor thing
but I love the way the film cuts to
black before the big explosion of music
it's really subtle editing choices like
that that have always impressed me about
this movie now I've waited to the end to
talk about this because I have one big
issue with this movie and it's kind of a
plot hole see throughout the years I've
always been a little confused about the
Drake Hotel Bible scene where he looks
at the Bible he sees that it's stamped
by the Drake Hotel and then in his head
he's able to connect the Jim Phelps is
really job that Jim Phelps is the bad
guy now I understand that the reason
behind that is that Jim Phelps took that
Bible from the Drake Hotel in Chicago to
a completely different country so that
he could then quote the scriptures
needed to correspond with max through
emails so we find out that Jim Phelps
his really job thus Jim Phelps is really
alive thus Jim Phelps is really the bad
guy I get all of that the one line of
dialogue that makes it all confusing for
me is when Max is looking at Tom Cruise
and says Jobe was not known to quote
scripture but then later in the film Jim
Phelps says thou shalt not covet another
man's wife so he does quote scripture so
did he need the Bible to quote the
scripture which told Tom Cruise that
this is the bad guy but then max said
that he doesn't usually quote scripture
it's honestly just that one line of
dialogue from Max that makes it all a
little confusing for me besides that I
love Mission Impossible it's one of my
favorite action movies I think it has
fantastic direction a very cool hero
great score great stunts everything
about the movie also moves very well and
the characters are really entertaining
especially Ving Rhames as Luther
stickell I'm going to give Mission
Impossible and a and one other thing
that's really remarkable about this
movie there are no shootout scenes and
Ethan Hunt never once fires a gun that's
just another thing about the script and
Brian DePalma as a director they didn't
resort to a very easy action scene a big
shootout scene they had it all be
suspense and espionage and I love that
about this movie but if you wanted more
gunfights they certainly got that in
Mission Impossible too my review for
that will be coming very soon guys let
me know what you think of the first
Mission Impossible movie in the comments
below and thank you so much as always
for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes